[Music]
the 10 rings are stronger than anything
in your universe
watch this
[Music]
show off
[Music]
my bad
hey can we get real for a second we've
been friends for 10 years
i know that you don't like to talk about
your life
but a guy with a freaking machete
foreign arm
just chopped our butts in half
dj snakes
who are you
making major moves my father trained me
to view the 10 rings greatest
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you find me
i always know where my children are
like a nice fella
it's time to show the world
oh hell no i'm not doing this
[Music]
you are a product of all who came before
[Music]
i must stop him hell yeah
[Music]
you can hear me
marvel studios sean chi and the legend
of the 10 reigns in theater september
3rd
[Music]
those who came before us
who made us who we are today
a legacy
of warriors
everything you need is already inside of
you
just not going back
you're ready
for all the training all the sacrifice
no one can hide forever
it's time to show the world
who i really am hell
studios yeah chi radipg 13. two weeks
ago you were parking cars and you want
me to believe you're now saving the
world yeah
in theater september 3rd
[Music]
you